so ladies are you ready to host the
oscars yeah we're going to crush this we
just have to do better than last year's
host that is the thing yes totally it is
a competition and i remember last year's
host god they must have sucked i bet
they got canceled i totally love the
oscars and i've watched it my whole life
people who act like you know too cool
for school that's not me i really
always look forward to the oscars i love
watching the red carpet before
and i like to gamble on it i think i'm
probably not allowed to gamble on it
this year
um but if anybody
will let me
you know how to find me
because i want to bet on myself
to black out by nine well being a
stand-up it's like you know just just
the muscle that i have and we
use it often you don't know what you're
gonna get so um and to me that's the
most you know that's the that's the fun
part so i i expect something crazy to
happen and you know some uh
i think that's what keeps it exciting
i was
really excited and then i was actually
terrified
i mean i think it's a show that i've
watched for so long you know from
childhood to adulthood so
there's such a range of feelings you
know but then you do realize like oh my
goodness it's the oscars i feel really
blessed because i have two incredible
co-hosts so i feel like what's been
what's been so fun thus far is being
able to collaborate and bounce ideas and
like just do a lot of fun stuff so how
am i preparing to host the oscars a lot
of people are asking me
and i would say it's mostly been
with drinking
just a lot of drinking like the kind of
drinking like yesterday is the only day
i didn't drink and i drank you know that
kind of drinking i'm watching the the
nominated films i'm doing that
and also
uh
you know watched some of the the past
uh host and i said i'm not gonna do that
there's so many things that make a great
oscar telecast the movies because that's
why we're here and my outfits i think
that's it
but not in that order
it does continue to be a tough year for
everyone and i think everyone's ready to
have a good time i think people want
that night to escape and laugh
and you know see celebrities
make
fools of themselves that's why we're all
here
you know just so we can like trash each
other